My husband woke up craving enchiladas, which is no surprise,
so I decided to make them for him for dinner.
I got started that afternoon
by removing the stems and seeds from Wahiyo,
California and ancho chilies and then charring them over the stove.
Meanwhile, I quickly prepared some of my non toxic
all purpose cleaner from Branch Basics,
which is the only product I buy to clean the entire house laundry
reincluded the chili sauce is blended together with some herbs.
Soboia Yahoo we saw,
along with some of the cooking water so it's not too thick.
I separated the whole chicken I had baked the day before,
shredded it, then seasoned it with salt.
Making the enchiladas takes a little finesse
and I started by dipping organic
corn tortillas into the enchilada sauce,
then frying it in tallow
and then rolling it up with chicken and raw cheese.
I lined a casserole dish with the enchiladas
and topped with raw cheese and foil
and let that bake for about 20 minutes
while I cleaned my charred pans and loaded the dishwasher.
The grease and grime came right off of my pan
after a brief 10 minutes soak.
So crazy cool.
And these cleaning products are so natural
you can wash your berries in it.
There's nothing quite like a fully loaded enchilada.
So I prepared my toppings along with some raw crema
so that when the enchiladas came out of the oven
they were ready to be loaded.
With the clean kitchen and family at the dining table,
I topped the enchiladas off with the salsa.
Chopped lechuga saboya e crema.
Las enchiladas estaban mues abrosas,
which means they were so flavorful and we loved them.